[Music]
[Applause]
I'm here with Gabrielle Gautier of
kester depo at the ftth council workshop
here in Valencia Gabrielle thanks for
talking to us we've grabbed you out of
this workshop what was the main subject
of what you were talking about today the
topic of the workshop was Jose only
models for fiber so we were mentioning
what was happening in some of the
European markets Sweden Germany UK or
Iceland's because the Nordic countries
have been looking at fiber with a
wholesale only model for longer than the
other countries Italy is now looking at
it with open fiber and in France we have
been looking at this model and for 18
years now 2000 we started with the
backhaul of the fiber and now of course
the FTTH theme the access and what we're
trying to do is to is to see it and to
view it as an essential infrastructure
that needs to be wholesaler only I mean
for you what have been some of the big
changes of the last two or three years
the biggest changes for us who have been
early investors is to see that others
were joining in and have been massively
joining in in the last two or three
years I was in London last Thursday
receiving the best PPP PFI project
telecom project awarded for a huge fiber
project in contest in France it's over 1
billion infrastructure project and I can
tell you it's one of the biggest
infrastructure projects and I deal with
and at the Casa de for I deal with other
types of vertical infrastructure
projects ports airports railroads
highways waste energy so this fiber open
access fiber over the whole contest
region of France was awarded the best
pvp and award by Thomson Reuters and why
is it a success because now we are not
the only investor
we are co investors with private
long-term infrastructure funds like
Marguerite like ER and others and the
banks are lending so it is now fiber is
now viewed as a normal infrastructure
when it is structured with a wholesale
model and of course really it's only
just the start in the fact I think
people are acknowledging that fiber is
so critical to things like 5g IOT
there's so much more to come for sure
when you build such an infrastructure
you build it future proof first of all
its its future proof because it's
following they in the it's this the way
of technology technology is moving to
network function virtualization and so
an essential infrastructure has to be
future for for all the future
generations are what's going to happen
in platforms 5g IOT and that's why also
it needs to be open and even if IOT is
not going to perhaps need a lot of broad
bandwidth it will have to be an open
access because do you see cities
opening up their their their pavements
three or four times and to deal with all
these little small cell and femtocells
on bus poles or on the on the walls of
buildings no so you will have fiber will
be one essential infrastructure fit for
everything especially for all the future
generations to come and the future of
mobile and of IOT and a 5g s5m very
interesting fascinating sort you thank
you for joining us you're welcome
you
[Applause]